let's go to um
matt the social studies guy welcome matt
what's going on
hey david um so i wanted to ask are you
familiar with um jamie raskin had
mentioned um
oh this is a few weeks back now he had
mentioned that there's going to be um
public hearings of information uncovered
uh starting next month i believe it is
january 9th the january 6th committee
i'm sorry june 9th the january 6th
committee hearing start
um and i i also want to know i believe
his quote he used was uh you know the
the things that are going to come to
light you know paraphrasing but uh
they're going to blow the the roof off
the house
and now my question is
yeah i think it's a great idea um and i
i would think you would agree you know
we all kind of want to know what has
been uncovered we want to know you know
the nuts and bolts of what happened yeah
um and i know there's a good
portion of us probably all the left i
don't want to overstate that also want
to know what's going on
i also know there's a contingent on the
right who
right out of the gate they're just going
to say you know it's a partisan witch
hunt it's garbage it's fake news
you know what have you they're not going
to listen whatever is said
so my my question is
you know do you do you think there's a
portion of people on the fence who are
going to be swayed by this you know how
effective you think it's going to be in
actually
kind of getting people to see
you know
what really went on here i think that
the effect of the january 6th hearings
if they are what jamie raskin says
they're going to be
is going to be less about changing minds
but more about activating people because
remember we have very low voter turnout
in this country especially in midterms
so my optimistic hope would be and
there's no guarantee that this happens
if people who don't normally vote
hear in those hearings about the
terrible things that were done in trying
to steal the election and the lead up to
the trump riots that they will say you
know what i don't normally vote but this
time i'm going to so in my mind it's
more about activating people than it is
about changing minds
i see very good thank you all right
thank you for the call matt the social
studies guy that's going to do it for
calls today we will take a quick break
and be back with much more right after
this